[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter hi martin nice to see you
again
yes nice to see you
so what are we talking about today
well we're going to talk about preparing
for the latter rain
and the reason why
we thought it would be useful to talk
about something like this again
for
the umpteenth time
because more and more we are hearing
it's not time yet
and even
in our official ranks we are hearing
messages
you know don't confuse the issues of the
current events with the biblical
prophecies the time is not yet
and
there have been articles written for
example
that state that
this issue about the earth being about 6
000 years old
cannot be used because you know it is
something that is just a general
statement and
you can't use it to say where we are in
the stream of time
and we have an urgency to get a message
of warning out and there are all these
break shoes that are smoking already
from all the breaks that people are
putting on
and so we felt we need to talk about
these things again and just reiterate a
few points true because if you don't
prepare for it you might be too late for
it
this latter ring you might be too late
so
why don't you pray for us that we can
start this ball rolling yes
our heavenly father
thank you
for all the blessings that you bestow
upon us
lord we know that the time is short and
we know that jesus is on his way to come
and fetch us so help us
in putting these discussions together
and enlighten our minds with the holy
spirit in jesus name amen
so martin some time ago we spoke about
the 6 000 years on the cosmic week
and
there was
much
ado about this issue
and many climbed onto the bandwagon to
condemn any kind of time setting etc
we weren't time setting we were talking
about
the edge of the earth and the 6 000 year
period
and
well
so let's look at the statement
which doesn't come from the pen of ellen
white
and it's an interesting one so let's
just read it for
introductory purposes
the vision of le vette's grove ohio on a
sunday afternoon in mid-march
1858 was one of great importance
in this the theme of the great
controversy between christ and his
angels on the one side
and satan and his angels on the other
was seen as one continuous and closely
linked chain of events
spanning six thousand years
this vision has put seventh-day
adventists into a unique position with
clear-cut views
of the working of providence in the
history of our world
a viewpoint quite different from that
held by secular historians
who see events of history as the
interplay between the actions of men
often seemingly the result of chants or
natural developments
in other words this vision and others of
the great conflict of the ages yield the
philosophy of history
that answers many questions and in
prophetic forecast gives the assurance
of final victory of good over evil
now here's a statement
that says that this vision
was of such a nature that it was clearly
shown
that the whole conflict stretches over 6
000 years
and
when not time setting let's make this
quite clear
but if you look at the biblical evidence
there are some discrepancies within
the bible and the masoretic text exactly
when the 6000 are over and not so you
cannot calculate it with absolute
certainty
but the masoretic text clearly tells us
that it's about 6 000 years
that we're dealing with
currently right
then we have the statements by ellen
white about the 6 000 years irrespective
of how close
we are to a specific time
and then you have this one which clearly
says that the conflict will stretch over
6 000 years
and then you have theologians and
leaders who are saying
no it's still for a long time
and this bothers
me and i'm sure it bothers you
because
the events
taking place in the world today
are so prophetic
that if you miss the connection you
might just miss the boat that's it and
why it's bothering me as well is there
is in the bible the statement that in
the end you'll have scoffers yes so when
you have to put that into place when
will that be
so we're not saying
when no we're saying
the 6 000 years must be coming to
completion
therefore the events taking place in the
world cannot be uncoupled yes
from what we are seeing transpiring
and this is an
urgency which we feel to tell the world
get ready
get ready this is not a blimp on the
horizon this is the forerunner of the
final event that's it
and people can scoff as much as they
like
and the theologians can quote the
septuagint as much as they please the
subdue again as we've discussed in many
many of our discussions so far
contradicts itself within itself
has methuselah surviving the flood
and stretches the ages so that
nothing makes any sense anymore and they
just
love to quote
this so-called
source of wisdom
it contradicts the masoretic text it
clearly contradicts the spirit of
prophecy why anybody who has any
knowledge of these things would even
want to use it boggles my mind
and let's be quite straight about that
so we have particular information we
have our bibles
and the masoretic text is the one that
the reformers accepted as canonical
and
we are reformers in the truest sense of
the word and therefore believe that god
was responsible for inspiring them
to use what they use that applies to the
new testament as well
they were inspired
to use the receive text
i'm surprised when i read some of our
publications and even those that are
supposed to be studied on a weekly basis
that they don't use
that
received text
at all
or marginally
and then they are surprised that they
cannot prove any of our distinctive
doctrines because they're just not there
in these catholic approved versions
now that's just one of the issues that
is bothering
so this statement is very important
because it clearly says one continuous
and closely linked chain of events
spanning 6 000 years
and then it also says
that it changes our whole view of
history yes then why do many of our
leaders
and our theologians want to stretch this
into a so much longer period
it doesn't make any sense to me
and another point also in the statement
is that it puts seventh-day adventists
in a unique position with clear-cut
views
which are as clear as mud
when you look at some of the statements
that are coming out in in this
denomination so now if you if you we all
agree and we see how important this is
we have we can put one voice out there
and tell the world listen
if we
really look at what the bible and spirit
of prophecy says what is supposed to be
the signs to look for and we know
okay this is the period that it is
getting very near
your voice can be so much louder correct
and
you know
we know that the lord can delay his
coming
we know that the time of the end can be
cut short yeah
so
taking the statement
for what it is we are
virtually dancing on the edge right
now
if you look at the events unfolding
around us
and you see how they fit the prophetic
scenario
shouldn't that
put a thrill down your spine and wake
you up
i can't think that you're not waking up
unless you want to be in a slumber
i think some people
love
slumbering
so let's just go through the issues
again just to get this thing clear
in our minds and to
give a particular message for a
particular time
and you know the lord says it's the
wicked servant that says the lord delays
his coming
now i would go
on this er on the side of leniency and
say sometimes the deceived servant also
falls into that category
the third angel's message is swelling
into a loud cry
and you must not feel at liberty to
neglect the present duty and still
entertain the idea that at some future
time you will be the recipient of great
blessing
when without any effort on your part a
wonderful revival will take place
today
you are to give yourselves to god that
he may make you vessels unto honor and
meet for his service
today
you are to give yourself to god that you
may be emptied of self
emptied of envy jealousy evil surmising
strife everything that shall be
dishonoring to god
today you ought to have your vessel
purified that it may be ready for the
heavenly jew ready for the showers of
the latter rain
for the latter rain will come
and the blessings of god will fill every
soul that is purified from every
defilement
it is our work today to yield our souls
to christ
that we may be fitted for the time of
refreshing from the presence of the lord
fitted for the baptism of the holy
spirit
it is imperative
that we prepare the soul temple for the
outpouring of the holy spirit
if we are of the opinion
that these things are still
far in the future
would we then not continue with our
humdrum
isn't it essential
that we make a covenant with god martin
isn't that essential
absolutely
you can always
procrastinate
and then put off things
and ah it's okay do it tomorrow do it
tomorrow
but once you get this like you said
throw down your spine
and you realize what can be the
consequences if you don't adhere and
don't do all these nice things to
cleanse yourself and get in line with
god then
you realize this is something you have
to do you cannot wait
even if even if
christ is not coming soon
even if
isn't that the right thing to do it's
better
to prepare yourself and he doesn't come
soon than not doing it and he does come
absolutely so these are things
that uh
you know we should put on the table
it should become a discussion point
because
this lackadaisial attitude that we find
in the world and
not only a lackadaisical attitude but an
attitude of
let's conform
to what the norms and standards of the
world are or the requirements of the
world
when this is a time when we should be
putting into the balance and weighing in
the balance the requirements of the
world and the requirements of god
and we need to
have a serious relationship i agree and
i think at this point in time we should
stand out
somebody must see
we are different than the world yes we
have an urgency
here's another statement from the desire
of ages but these statements are well
known
but we need to we need to put our minds
into a situation
where we grasp the seriousness
of the times we are living in
it's not just preparing for a calamity
that is coming
it is preparing to meet your god that's
it and that means that something must be
right in here you must say this is our
god we have waited for him and he will
save us you must be able to have this
relationship and this confidence that
you can shout that with
with
with joy and you know that just puts
something for me in perspective
you you sometimes hear people say ah but
we just fear mongering and we just
continue to speak negative and we always
want to scare people
if you get yourself in line with god and
you start realizing how he wants you to
change
you will also see this different you
won't see when we put out what's going
on in the signs as fear-mongering no
you'll understand wow this is our god
this is on his way
we have to get other people
warned that is the exact point and what
did jesus say go ye into all the world
and preach the gospel
and if you know that the time is short
that will create an urgency to tell
someone else
that's why in this ministry
we we want to make it as easy as
possible to share the message
not because we we think that you know
this message is something that emanates
from us but because of the seriousness
of the issue it's got to go out there
so let's read this statement
those who take christ at his word
and surrender their souls to his keeping
their lives to his ordering will find
peace and quietude
that's what you just said in a time of
turmoil
how many letters do we receive of people
who are absolutely despaired
hundreds hundreds right
and phone calls yes what must we do
they will find peace and quietude
nothing of the world can make them sad
when jesus makes them glad by his
presence in perfect acquiescence
there's perfect rest the lord says thou
will keep him in perfect peace whose
mind is stayed on thee because he trusts
us in thee it's a beautiful quote from
isaiah 26 3.
our lives may seem a tangle
but as we commit ourselves to the wise
master worker he will bring out the
pattern of life and character
that will be to his own glory and that
character which expresses the glory the
character of christ
will be received into the paradise of
god
so when moses
beheld the glory of god and his face
sean
that is the character
and that is the character that we should
emulate
did jesus pour out his soul to win
people to the faith
yes continually continue what we did
that's what he did that should be our
mindset
not a mindset of complacency
so let's just recap
the signs of christ's coming
particularly in view of the fact that
there are these voices that are going up
and saying you know
we are we are confusing people
this is not the time when the mark of
the beast will be implemented this is
something totally different and
you know
what is happening in the world is also
not the mark of the beast we are aware
of that
but if it is a precursor
then it's time to wake up yep
so let's look at the signs of christ's
return
christ forewarned his disciples of the
destruction of jerusalem and the signs
to take place prior to the coming of the
son of man
the whole of the 24th chapter
of matthew is a prophecy concerning the
events to precede this event and the
destruction of jerusalem is used to
typify
the last great destruction of the world
by fire
christ upon the mount of olives
rehearsed the fearful judgments that
were to precede his second coming
you shall hear of wars and rumors of
wars let's just stop
there are there rumors of war
there's yeah
serious ones right exactly
have some of the leaders actually said
that
they would not hesitate to push the
nuclear button yeah
yes and all the
nations that are now
in
a
conflict situation are all nuclear
powers
nations shall arise against nation
kingdom against kingdom there shall be
famines is the talk of famine
pestilences
earthquakes
we've shown all of this we've just in
our own country had a series of
earthquakes
which is unheard of for this particular
country some of them were felt even here
even in our little town
that's incredible
all these are the beginning of sorrows
while these prophecies received a
partial fulfillment at the destruction
of jerusalem
they have a more direct application in
the last days
nobody can deny that we are seeing
turmoil on the planet nobody can deny
that we've had major earthquakes
volcanic eruptions
storms you name it
and i just want to bring this in now
because scoffers will usually say yeah
but we've had this for two thousand
four thousand years
again emphasizing
listen
put it into perspective
if you take the intensity and the amount
of
these calamities happening now it's
never been like this it's never been
like this you're absolutely right
now martin we've had this on the screen
so many times
that's not the point of this discussion
this point is
please take note of what is happening in
the world
at the close of the great papal
persecution christ declared the sun
should be darkened and the moon should
not give her light
we had those historic events the great
meteor shower
we've had the darkening of the sun where
the cattle went
and the sheep went to their pens and the
chickens to their roost
etc these have all happened
years ago already and it's well
documented by not
this denomination by secular people that
it was totally out of the place the
darkness
and all of this and it's in in the local
new newspapers of the time
and he says learn a parable of the fig
tree when his branches hear tender and
put us forth leaves
you know that summer is nigh so likewise
ye when you shall see all these things
know that he's near even at the door
christ has given signs of his coming he
declares that we may know when he is
near even at the door he says of those
who see these signs
this generation shall not pass till all
these things be fulfilled
these signs have appeared
now we know of a surety that the lord's
coming is at hand
now we had a whole what's a prof
on
all the events that need to be in place
in a particular time in order to know
that we are in the final generation
so there again
how can people put this off for 100 or
200 years
if they study the bible
and they study the spirit of prophecy i
cannot comprehend how they can come up
with notions like that
jesus declares there shall be sign in
the sun and the moon and the stars and
upon the earth distress of nations
those who behold these hobbingers of his
coming are to know that he is near even
at the door
again
and again we get this admonition
even at the door
times of perplexity are upon us men's
hearts are failing them for fear of the
things that are coming upon the earth
but those who believe in god will hear
his voice amid the storm saying it is i
be not afraid and that is the crux of
the matter
if we continue to discuss these signs
and this nearness of the coming that is
the words that you want to utter we want
to hear god utter to you yes and
it will give you a calmness
people are so afraid of of the so-called
hype that it's causing
because they are so afraid let's put it
bluntly
that prophecy won't be fulfilled and
they'll look like fools
can you be a fool for getting somebody
ready for christ's coming
at any time no you cannot be a fool it's
impossible
but they are so scared
that the prophecies won't be fulfilled
and therefore
they will say
alarmists
or conspiracy theorists or whatever i'd
rather have those labels and do my duty
than to be a procrastinator i'm with you
strange and eventful history is being
recorded in the books of heaven events
which it was declared should shortly
precede
the great day of god everything in the
world is in an unsettled state
is that a fact of history
definitely have you ever had the world
in such an unsettled state not the way
it is now
not in your life
i don't think even during the second
world war was the whole world in a state
like it is now yes how many suicides are
taking place people are are jumping off
buildings exactly that uh miss
usa yes it just jumped off
what greater honor can you have than to
be crowned one of the princes
and queens of whatever and then you jump
off because there's nothing left
because there's no inner peace because
there's no anchor
and the false prophets as one of the
signs of jerusalem's destruction christ
had said many false prophets shall arise
and shall deceive many
false prophets did arise deceiving the
people and leading great numbers into
the desert magicians and sorcerers
claiming miraculous powers
drew the people after them into the
mountain solitudes
but this prophecy was spoken also for
the last days
the sign is given as a sign of the
second advent
we shall encounter false claims false
prophets will arise there will be false
dreams false visions but preach the word
be not drawn away from the voice of god
in his word now let's just stop there
why are we putting this there
martin the world today
believes a
jesuitical version of end time events
yes
that is the main problem futurism yeah
and
they also telling us that it will be an
earthly kingdom
and it comes straight out of the pen of
jesuits
and people
think that it is fine because the
jesuits are the educators of the world
and everybody clamors to get into a
jesuitical university even our
theologians clamor to get into a
jesuitical university what can you learn
from an infidel except infidelity that's
it
nothing right
and even if you are prepared
you can become tainted by that way of
thinking
and then eventually you will
choose whatever has been planted over
what has been
revealed
i've been shown
many who will claim to be especially
taught of god and will attempt to lead
others and from mistaken ideas of duty
they will undertake a work that god has
never laid upon them
confusion will be the result let
everyone seek god most earnestly for
himself that he may
individually understand his will let's
just stop there
where do we find a revelation
of his will
in the word of god
right there yeah now the bible is
written by many people
and there are so many versions of the
bible today
and
those versions contradict each other
but
god has given us another witness as well
the spirit of prophecy which happens to
be in harmony with the written word
and particularly if you take a book like
hebrews for example
you cannot support
the doctrine of the sanctuary from the
modern translations correct
and yet it is clearly written in the
spirit of prophecy if people would take
a book for example like first selected
messages
right
and read there you will see what is
quoted why it is quoted and how it
confirms
the the view on the sanctuary message it
is of paramount importance
for the times in which we are living
you cannot use the modern translations
at all to support any of those doctrines
and therefore the modern versions not
only contradict the received text they
also contradict the spirit of prophecy
why would anyone want to do that
it surprises me so if i want to know
what his will is
i need to study what god said
and i want to know
what god said not what somebody thinks
god said i want to know what god said
that is the way that you will
individually understand his will
that's the way there's no other way god
speaks to you through the written word
that's it you cannot go to somebody else
and he tells you what god said
because then you don't get that
individuality that you have to have with
god
and
this is what we need to do we need to
understand what is god's will
so we need to understand our bible and
we need to understand what it says
and we need
in these days i believe
to have this extra source that
corroborates what it says in that word
and if there is a conflict between a
translation
and
the spirit of prophecy
then check it in the received text and
if there is no conflict between the
received text and the spirit of prophecy
then accept that as the norm yes because
you've got witnesses we would have far
less confusion
now but it's possible that people can be
confused in the times that we are living
in there are so many discordant noises
and there are so many methodologies that
are being employed today
that people base what they believe on
an inner action on a feeling
and the interesting case that happened
in the past when
a young man in the time of ellen white
was giving certain messages and these
were not necessarily in harmony
with
what the denomination had been studying
in the word of god
it's interesting to see how she dealt
with this issue
last night a young man a stranger to us
all by professing to be a brother from
victoria
australia called upon us and asked to
see sister white
it was evening and i declined seeing him
we invited him to remain with us during
the night however and to take breakfast
after our usual morning worship as we
were about to go to our various
employments
this young man arose and with a
commanding gesture requested us to sit
down
he said have you any hymnbooks we will
sing him then i have a message to give
you i said
if you have a message give it without
delay for we are very much pressed to
get off the american mail and have no
time to lose
he then began to read something he had
written which stated amongst other
things that the judgment has now begun
upon the living
i listened as he went on and finally
said my brother you're not exactly in
your right mind
state plainly how your message concerns
us please let us know at once
your mind is over strange you
misapprehend your work
much that you have said is in accordance
with the bible and we believe every word
of that
but you are over-excited
please state
what you have for us
well he said
that we must pack up and move it once to
battle creek i asked his reason and he
responded to give this message that the
judgment has begun upon the living i
answered him the work which the lord has
given us to do is not yet finished when
our work here is completed we are sure
the lord will let us know
that it is time for us to move to battle
creek
instead of teaching you our duty
i left him with brother star to talk
with further while i resumed my writing
he told brother star that when sister
white spoke to him so kindly and yet
with such authority he began to see that
he had made a mistake
that the impressions which had moved him
so strongly were not consistent or
reasonable
although our family is large consisting
of 10 members besides three visitors we
decided to have this young man stay with
us for a time
we dare not have him go with people who
will treat him harshly and condemn him
neither do we want him to repeat his
revelations
we will have him remain for a little
while where we can associate with him
and if possible
lead him in safe sure
paths a modern why would we read
something like that
well
it is very evident
that there are many in our
ranks
that know exactly what everybody's duty
is
isn't that the case
and they will tell you in no uncertain
terms
and sometimes they will be
very adamant as to
exactly what your duty is and what your
decisions should be
in relation to what is happening in the
world today yes
they're very prescriptive they have no
such duty
that is an individual
issue between god
and us
and if i tell you
or you tell me that god has shown you
what my duty is and god has shown me
what your duty is
then you have the fullest right to say
i will wait till god reveals to me
what my duty is and if it happens to be
the same as what you propose
then very well
but in the time that we are living in
we must base our decision
on the bible
on the spirit of prophecy
and in the light of that what we feel
god
is wanting us to do
to act upon or to decide
nobody has the right to tell you
or anyone else what their duty is
and as they stated quite plainly you
know if it is in the bible
like remember the sabbath day to keep it
holy well then yes the bible says keep
the sabbath day
but if it says that you must receive
this medication or that medication or
else
i don't read it there
in fact i read the contrary
in the spirit of prophecy
and therefore i must wait until god
convinces me and not necessarily act if
somebody thinks it is their duty to tell
me or you what we should do yes and
individual choice
are we nearing the end
definitely so
you will
more and more get people telling you
your duty
all right is it absolutely necessary in
the times that we are living
that we have this personal relationship
with god
and base our decisions on our personal
study
and
facts
that can be presented
but that there be no coercion of any
kind
definitely
because more and more who are the main
people that are going to try and tell
you your duty
it's going to be the state
yes so when you
get people joining the state you know
it's especially church
it's we can see red lights
and then you have to be pretty sure
that
what they are proposing is actually in
harmony
with what the lord's revealed will is
so
another very important issue is the
issue of intemperance and gluttony
gluttony and intemperance lie at the
foundation of the great moral depravity
in our world
it's quite an interesting statement did
you know martin that if you make a study
of the spirit of prophecy and this word
gluttony
it is often associated with excessive
meat eating
satan is aware of this and he is
constantly tempting men and women to
indulge the taste at the expense of
health and even life itself
eating drinking and dressing
or made the aim of life with the world
just such a state of things existed
before the flood
and this state of dissipation is one of
the marked evidences of the soon
close of this earth's history
has there ever been a time
when
food has been more prominent in the
media
than at the current times in which we
are living
it's it's a war of its own i think it's
a there's
not even rumors of war
in food and and what what is going on in
the food industry and it's a nightmare
what is placed into the food how they
manipulate the food all of these things
must surely be signs
of the soon coming of the lord
but
if you believe
that god is the creator of everything
and that everything was good
it was very good
and that god had a original diet and
original purpose for humanity
if that is so would he record it in his
word
yes
did he record it in his word yes
did humanity adhere to it or tend to
move away from it they tend to move away
from it
did he constantly tried to bring them
back to it he did and they misinterpret
that he allowed
the other
portion but god doesn't coerce and he
doesn't force the conscience
but there are consequences
he allows the consequences
so if we look at at this issue
can we say that from this point of view
with the manipulation that we see in the
food industry
particularly in the food industry
pertaining to
animal products
and now increasingly also pertaining to
plant products with genetic
modifications that are taking place
using plants for
methodologies that are outside the realm
of what god has implanted
in these things
isn't that a sign that we are close to
the end definitely because
your main
your main substance for having a clear
mind is your food
so obviously the enemy of god will
attack that part first all right now
i'm a bit older than you
but even within your lifetime
even within your lifetime have you seen
dramatic changes in the food industry oh
yes
for the better or for the worse for the
worse i grew up on a farm
so i can tell you the difference that i
saw in the past 20
years amazing all right
now
if god is in control
then
you must be able to imagine
that a loving god
would surely not want to see his people
destroyed by all of these unhealthful
practices right
so the fact that he's letting loose the
winds because they so constantly resist
him
is that a sign that we are close to the
last days yes
it says that okay
we know that the lord is coming very
soon the world is fast becoming as it
was in the days of noah
it is given over to selfish indulgence
eating and drinking or carried to excess
men are drinking the poisonous liquor
that makes them mad
now
the excess
has been increasing it's a sign of the
times you know what
you remember one of the things that
happened in our country
with the lockdowns is they
forbid liquor sales
and it was
crazy how people
went on
over that
not only that how
they tried to circumvent it how they
broke into the stores to get hold of the
liquor and
they were producing their own liquor in
their backyards and so people are
absolutely committed to overindulgence
in all of these things it's a sign of
the last days
what about deeds of violence
in the days of noah the overwhelming
majority was opposed to the truth
and enamored with a tissue of falsehoods
the land was filled with violence
war crime murder
was the order of the day just so will it
be before christ's second coming
what's happening in the cities of the
world now
it's forgetting very bad especially in
cities that used to be quite
decent
now here's a question
cities that have thrown overboard the
rule of law
and released criminals back into the
world in their droves
aren't they suffering the most yes it's
very bad at this stage
so
god's people are supposed to keep god's
law the world has set aside god's law
and in fact
they seem hell-bent to set aside man's
laws as well
and
you know we can see this in the times
that we are living in
is that a sign that christ is coming
soon
what's happening in the cities of
america
if you read the news it's it's
incredible
some of our cities in our country you
don't want to go in there
any time of the day let alone in the
middle of the night right
so the labor unions are quickly stirred
to violence if their demands are not
complied with plainer and plainer is it
becoming
that the inhabitants of the world are
not in harmony with god
no scientific theory
can explain the steady march of evil
workers under the generalship of satan
in every mob wicked angels are at work
rousing men to commit deeds of violence
the perversity and cruelty of men will
reach such a height
that god will reveal himself in his
majesty
very soon the wickedness of the world
will have reached its limit
and as in the days of noah
god will pour out his judgment
the terrible reports we hear of murders
and robberies of railway accidents deeds
of violence
let's tell the story that the end of all
things is at hand now just now
we need to be preparing for the lord's
second coming
martin we're trying to tell people
not to become complacent
not to fall asleep even if it appears as
if there is a slight reprieve on the
horizon
with the laws that are in place there
will be no reprieve yeah it's like we
mentioned before
you think everything is now in a calm
state
but you still the law the things that
were implemented has not been withdrawn
acknowledged don't get into a state of
complacency
all right so we can clearly see that all
of the issues that we've mentioned have
escalated dramatically
even within the last year
and people say
the lord's coming
is a long way or
the tempest is coming and we must get
ready for its fury by having repentance
towards god and faith towards our lord
jesus christ
the lord will arise to shake terribly
the earth we shall see troubles on all
sides
thousands of ships will be hurled into
the depth of the sea
navies will go down human lives will be
sacrificed by the millions
fires will break out unexpectedly
no human effort will be able to quench
them have you ever seen those some of
them
yes all right we saw ships go down in
the second world war
do you think this is what we're talking
about or are there conflicts in the air
between the navies of the world yes i
this will be
coming soon what's happening in the
south china sea
does china say that it has a larger navy
than the united states of america at the
moment yes
all right is there activity in the
baltic
with the russian navy and the nato navy
yeah so is it possible that we could
have tremendous conflicts taking place
soon
the palaces of earth will be swept away
in the fury of the flames
now what in the palaces of the earth are
still standing most of them right
so in the context
if you look at the time frame that we're
talking about here
we're not talking about the time frame
of the second world war correct right
yeah because this seems to indicate that
this is something that is waiting that
will take place
disasters by rail will become more and
more frequent confusion collision death
without a moment's warning will occur in
the great lines of travel the end is
near
probation is closing oh let us seek god
while he may be found to call upon him
while he is near
and the last scenes of this earth
history
war will rage so there again within the
context
this is something that we should be
expecting in our time
are the conditions now such
that these things are a possibility it's
escalating also very quickly
okay there's a lot of tension
the next statement is fascinating the
waters of the deep will overflow their
boundaries
we're talking about tsunamis here
overflow their boundaries a tsunami
overflows its boundaries have we had
tsunamis lately
dramatic ones yes
property and life will be destroyed by
fire and flood we should be preparing
for the mansions that christ has gone to
prepare for them that love them have we
had tremendous floods in
europe
yes
in asia yes in africa in our country
everywhere
so in the context that we are reading
here
we are not looking at events that have
passed now we are looking at events that
are ahead of us
and everything
is
in place
every single one of them
last friday morning just before i awoke
a very impressive scene was presented
before me
i seemed to awake from sleep but was not
in my home
from the windows i could behold the
terrible confrontation great balls of
fire were falling upon houses and from
these balls
fiery arrows were flying in every
direction it was impossible to check the
fires
that were kindled
and many places were being destroyed the
terror of the people was
indescribable
after a time i awoke and find myself at
home
here's another one i saw an immense ball
of fire amongst some beautiful mansions
causing their instant destruction i
heard someone say
we knew that the judgments of god were
coming upon the earth but we did not
know that they would come so soon
others with agonized voices said you
knew
why then did you not tell us we did not
know
now some people would like to apply this
to 911.
but these are falling amongst mansions
yes and houses and
it's definitely not on the buildings in
manhattan so this is something that we
must expect will take place soon right
yes and like the last sentence
warns us
you knew
and you did not tell us
that's our mission
now martin
do we hear
from
our church in general
a great urgency to get the final message
out
not in general not in general right
we have pockets that want to get the
message out that hand out the great
controversy
that try to bring a loud cry message
that tell the people that the time is
short now those that do that do they get
the full support or are they largely
ridiculed you are largely ridiculed
what do you say to that what do you do
well firstly you have to go on to your
knees
and ask the lord to help you through
these days
and then
we should
wake up the people
by not stopping
our preaching
all right so are you trying to tell me
that we dare not
allow ourselves to be influenced by
voices
that say that the time is not yet
absolutely
don't stop because everything i've been
reading here
tells me that the time
is now yes
so
that's basically
why
we want to reiterate it
that we are absolutely convinced that
the time of the end is right before us
not because of time setting
but because the signs are there
and the time is short because this
controversy
plays out over 6 000 years
that is biblical and that is in harmony
with the spirit of prophecy so let no
one
let no one convince you otherwise
look at the signs
ask god to prepare your heart
the enemy has worked and he is working
still he's coming down in great power
and the spirit of god is being withdrawn
from the earth
god has withdrawn his hand
we have only to look at johnstown
pennsylvania
he did not prevent the devil from wiping
that whole city out of existence
an estimated 2200 people lost their
lives and johnstown flood when a dam
broke after many days of heavy rain
and these very things will increase
until the close of this earth's history
if i may come in here
that was 2 200 people in that one what
number of people are we talking these
days in a calamity yes and how many dams
have broken under the pressure lately
and whole villages been swept away
the earth's crust will be rent by the
outbursts of the elements concealed in
the bowels of the earth
these elements once broken loose will
sweep away the treasures of those who
for years
have been adding to their wealth by
securing large possessions at starvation
prices
from those in their employ
and the religious world too
is to be terribly shaken for the end of
all things is at hand
the time has now come when one moment we
may be on solid earth the next the earth
will be heaving beneath our feet
earthquakes will take place when least
expected you know there's something that
i find interesting
all the reports of volcanic eruptions
lava pouring out
volcanoes that have been dormant
suddenly
coming alive
japan
the ring of fire
the volcanic activity is unprecedented
this
ring of fire is ablaze
at this stage now you know
the world's climatologists can say
climate change
no sin
god is withdrawing his hand
and we are seeing these things not
because of climate change
but because of the state of the world
and because god's protection is being
withdrawn that's it and the nearness of
his second coming
so in fires in floods in earthquakes in
the fury of the great deep in calamities
by sea and by land the warning is given
that god's spirit will not always strive
with men if you disconnect it like the
world does
by giving it some
natural reason
you miss the point
god is asking
us to get ready
and they are saying let's reduce carbon
stop breathing martin you're polluting
the air with carbon
that is ridiculous
if you compare it with the real reason
why things are taking place as they are
and the religious world will be a happy
partaker and we see that
all the time
we are now
become
the gospel of climate change adherence
instead of the gospel of christ the soon
coming of christ and the judgments that
go along with it
so before the son of man appears in the
clouds of heaven everything in nature
will be convulsed
climate change
according to the scientists yes
lightning from heaven uniting with fire
in the earth will cause the mountains to
burn like a furnace and pour out their
floods of lava over villages and cities
it is incredible what's going on now in
that particular field
molten masses of rock thrown down into
the water by the upheaval of things
hidden in the earth will cause the water
to boil and send forth rocks and earth
there will be mighty earthquakes and
great destructions of human life we've
just seen it in the pacific
and everybody says must be
climate change
let's just go a little bit deeper into
what the spirit of prophecy really says
about these issues
satan is working in the atmosphere
he is poisoning the atmosphere
and here we are to depend upon god for
our lives
our present and eternal lives and being
in the position that we are we need to
be wide awake holy devoted holy
converted wholly consecrated to god but
we seem to sit as though we were
paralyzed
god of heaven wake us up
god has not restrained the powers of
darkness from carrying forward their
deadly work of vetivating the air
one of the sources of life and nutrition
with a deadly miasma
not only is vegetable life affected but
man suffers from
pestilence
martin what are we reading here
we're reading that
there's toxins in there
who placed them there satan and his
agents aha so satan either directly or
with his agents
is there a possibility if we study the
current news events of the world
that something something like this is
taking place or is
it a total conspiracy theory
that the air is being tainted on purpose
now there's
more than enough evidence that it's
not just a conspiracy
it is actually a conspiracy but it's not
a theory
it's not a theory
now
do we hear people talking about uh
tainting the air
yep blocking out the sun
yes all kinds of interesting things that
they want to do now what happens then
not only is vegetable life affected
but man suffers from the pestilence
so are plants safeguarded from this no
right martin then
how would you deal with this kind of
issue
do you think there might be attempts to
mess with the food source yes
so you will have to look for yourself
so is it possible
that the food source can be deliberately
tampered with
we know that the food sources are
deliberately tampered with by
devitalizing them and removing
everything that's nutritious and
replacing that with these nutritious
with that which is harmful
that has been going on for a long time
but to deliberately change the food
sources is it possible that people could
be so wicked as to
add certain things
like nanobots or whatever people are
talking about into the food source if
they have the philosophy that the end
justifies the means then that's not that
will is what they will do um but martin
which organization has that philosophy
the jesuits the jesuits but these people
are
portrayed as the intellectuals and
heroes of the world but the the spirit
of prophecy portrays them as the enemies
of god's people and now we've got the
other problem that comes in that they've
changed that wording a bit and now
they've made it the common good
that end that justifies the means so now
if it's for the common good it sounds so
beautiful and every everybody wants to
do it
but if they manipulate your food or
anything else because it's for the
common good you won't even realize that
you're just part of their whole plan
so if we look at the history
of what they have done over the years
and what they have introduced into the
world
who started
the drug industry and the cocaine
industry in south america
who used all of these people in south
america for example to harvest their
cocaine industry
products and send them into the world
into their knights of malta companies to
pollute the whole of humanity who
introduced
the things like
caffeine products and coffee into the
western world wasn't it the jesuits yes
they were involved in all of that
and why not take it up another level
and yet they are supposed to be the
heroes the one that make the rules and
we're supposed to adhere to them
contrary to the word of god and to the
spirit of prophecy
it's incredible that people will go
along with this without asking the
question
is this one of the signs of the last
days
and to just brush it aside
as though it didn't exist or was a
glitch on the horizon is a very
dangerous road
to walk
so very clearly it says here these
things are the result of drops from the
vials of god's wrath
in other words god takes responsibility
for that which he allows or does not
prevent
being sprinkled on the earth and are but
faint representations of what will be in
the near future
but now we hearing more and more reports
of this here she forewarns it and we
sitting in a day where this is a reality
and people say the time is not yet
it is it is mind-boggling to me
famines will increase pestilence will
sweep away thousands dangers are all
around us from the powers without and
satanic workings within
but the restraining power of god is now
being exercised
so when this restraining power is
withdrawn
don't you want to be right with god
martin absolutely
is this not a time for serious
introspection every single day when you
open your eyes
this is the road you have to travel with
god
so even in her time i've been shown that
the spirit of the lord is being
withdrawn from the earth god's keeping
power will soon be refused
to all who continue to disregard his
commandments
the reports of fraudulent transactions
murders crimes every kind are coming to
us daily iniquity is becoming so common
a thing
that it is no longer that it no longer
shocks the census as it once did
how much more so in our time
it's amazing i don't think people can be
shocked anymore actually and the
legislation
the legislation is so blatantly against
the word of god it is like a a challenge
to god do something about it
and the world sits back and embraces the
evil rather than the truth
and we see it in all the countries of
the world simultaneously
legislation
that totally destroys the order that god
has put into humanity that's true even
countries that were
much more conservative and christian
it's gone now it's gone it's gone in
fact if you do the christian thing
you're ostracized
you are shouted down even by the
churches
so why does god allow the calamities
to show us that climate change is a
reality martin
what mean the awful calamities by sea
vessels held into eternity without a
moment's warning what mean the accidents
by land fire consuming the riches that
men have hoarded
much of which has been accumulated by
oppression of the poor
the lord will not interfere to protect
the property of those who transgress his
law
break his covenant and trample upon his
sabbath
accepting in its place a spurious rest
day
the plagues of god are already falling
upon the earth sweeping away the most
costly structures as if they were a
breath of fire from heaven
well not these judgments bring
professing christians to their senses
god permits them to come that the world
may take heed that sinners may be afraid
and tremble before him
god has a purpose in permitting these
calamities to occur they are one of his
means of calling men and women to their
senses
by unusual workings through nature
god will express to doubting human
agencies that which he clearly reveals
in his word
and here's the crux
if you do not study the word
you will attribute all these things to
some natural phenomenon
and if you listen to the words that come
out of the vatican
and the spokespersons of the vatican
then you will totally negate the word of
god because they're not grounded in the
work of word of god they're grounded in
their traditions
and their traditions are contrary to the
word of god
and yet the world follows these people's
advice yeah and even people within our
own ranks
say that that is the logical thing to do
to follow infidels who do not keep the
commandments of god and are at war with
the word
how frequently we hear of earthquakes
and tornadoes of destruction by fire and
flood with great loss of life and
property
apparently these calamities are
capricious outbreaks of disorganized
unregulated forces of nature wholly
beyond the control of man
but in them all god's purpose may be
read they are among the agencies by
which he seeks to arouse men and women
to a sense of their danger
if we don't see it in this perspective
we will see it
like the world ceases and we will follow
the beast
all the way
and receive his mock and his plagues yes
and the other thing that we have to keep
in mind now
is when we first read that satan puts a
deadly taint and all this into nature
and he studies the
laboratories of nature and so on
so god permits him to do this because he
has a purpose in everything god yes and
his purpose is like we've read earlier
to get you
to have your dependence on him and get
ready for him
now you know if you go to ancient
history
take the history of england for example
and you have the legends of king arthur
king arthur and the round table
and then in that time period you have
the stories of robin hood
and the decay of society and
the misuse
of power
and all of these terrible things and
everybody was waiting for
the return of king arthur to put
everything into perspective and put
everything right again right
of course if you look at those you'll
see
that they are actually twisted forms of
jesuitical theater that's all it is
now the world is waiting for a king
arthur
to come with his round table
with these twelve around one
his counterfeit of the bible and the
twelve disciples and christ to set the
matters right in other words they're
waiting for satan
to come and set the record straight
and he will and unfortunately they don't
know they waiting for satan yes because
they don't read they don't read
but here we read the world is not
without a ruler
the program of coming events is in the
hands of the lord
that's the bottom line
the majesty of heaven has the destiny of
nations as well as the concerns of his
church in his own church
so amidst the chaos
what do we need to do
keep our faith and focus yeah where
should our focus be on god on god
and not on what's happening here in the
world we're observers we're observers
you're right
these symbolic representations the fiery
serpents in the wilderness serve a
double purpose
from them god's people learn not only
that the physical forces of the earth
are under the control of the creator
but also that under his control are the
religious movements of the nations
especially is this true with reference
to the enforcement of sunday observance
now martin
we had let's talk about it
just recently
here in january did the world churches
come together to pray for the
implementation of this of the false
sabbath yes they had a whole week
a week of prayer
did the agenda for the year
include the
inversion of genesis chapter one yes
okay
isn't that a sign
isn't it a sign big sign
why do people not see that this is a
sign
that this is a sign that god has
withdrawn his restraining power and
permitted them to do
in his name
what is totally contrary to his will
unbelievable
in the great closing work we shall meet
with perplexities that we know not how
to deal with
but let us not forget
that the three great powers of heaven
are working that the divine hand is on
the wheel and that god will bring his
purpose to pass now instead
of god's people becoming all flustered
because of all these things happening in
the world
isn't this a time to say
god is permitting these things to happen
now
therefore i better get my relationship
right with him because very soon i'm
going to see him the time is at hand the
time is at hand the lord is coming
as the wheel-like complications were
under the guidance of the hand beneath
the wings of the cherubim
so the complicated play of human events
is under divine control
amidst the strife and tumult of nations
he that sitteth above the cherubim
still guides the affairs of earth
that's very good to know is no it's such
a relief
how can you say we are fear-mongering
if we know who's in charge
and if you look at the world and you see
the turmoil and you see the conflict of
interest and you see
governments in in acting draconian rules
based on conflicting contradictory
science
they must tell you there's something
seriously wrong when
thousands of people martin
climb into trucks
to say that they no longer want to go
along with these things
they will still enforce them
contrary to common sense
contrary even to science
and they will ignore the will of the
people
surely that must tell you
that we are
in the very closing moments of this
earth's history
in the annals of human history the
growth of nations the rise and fall of
empires appear as if dependent upon the
will and prowess of man
the shaping of events seemed to a great
degree to be determined by his power
ambition or caprice
didn't we hear even the religious
leaders like the pope say
that nobody's going to help us out of
this mess
that
we have to help ourselves out of this
mess this is something humanity must
save
it's just same with climate change
god can help cannot help us there's no
god in heaven right it doesn't exist
anymore it seems as if humanity has this
wonderful prowess
is this a sign of the times
and the arrogance of those statements
and then
there are people that hang on these
people's lips when they are so devoid of
the basic tenets of god word but
it is as you said there's a new god on
earth
and that's science
so everybody is hanging on to science
and making an idol out of science
but in the word of god
the curtain is drawn aside and we behold
above behind and through all the play
and counterplay of human interests and
power and passion
the agency of the all merciful ones
silently
patiently
working out the councils of his own will
isn't that comforting yeah it's
comforting to know that god's not
ruffled no he's still in control calmly
so what should i attitude be
the same
how many videos do you receive on a
daily basis
where people are saying this is
happening and that's happening and what
are we going to do about this and what
are we going to do about that and
and the other
it's going to happen right because god's
spirit is withdrawing
samadhin there are people that think
that
god is either impotent
or he is not interested
all right
but that's not what we read here
in sparing the life of the first
murderer god presented before the whole
universe a lesson
bearing upon the great controversy it
was his purpose not merely to put down
the rebellion but to demonstrate to all
the universe the nature of rebellion
the holy inhabitants of other worlds
were watching with the deepest interest
the events taking place on the earth
god carries with him the sympathy and
approval of the whole universe
as step by step his great plan advances
to its complete fulfillment
the act of christ dying for the
salvation of man would not only make
heaven accessible to men
but before all the universe it would
justify god and his son in their dealing
with the rebellion of satan
the whole universe is watching with
inexpressible interest the closing
scenes of the great controversy between
good and evil shouldn't we be watching
it too oh definitely or should we be
putting it off
no
no especially not and
this must put into perspective for
people that say why is god allowing all
of this
because it's
to prove him right
and it is proving him right yeah it is
proving him right
anybody who
dares to study the bible
and to find their comfort in the word of
god
will realize that god is permitting what
is happening
to inoculate you against the greatest
virus that has ever infected humanity
and it has a three-letter word and it
spells sin
right that's it
and what is sin
it is the transgression of god's law it
is an act contrary to the character of
god
but sin was such an evil injection
into
the humanity no pun intended with the
word injection
that god chose to bear the consequences
himself
and that forever
lays to rest whether god cares or not
that's it
and so this whole argument is god
involved
does god care has been laid to rest and
historically you can go and check it in
the word of god and then you will
realize that what god is permitting now
is a public display
of the consequence of the rejection of
his word
our little world is the lesson book of
the universe
this is an amazing
statement
in discussing christ's four thousand
year battle with satan and his ultimate
victory on the cross she uses such
phrases as the heavenly universe beheld
all heaven and the unfallen worlds had
been witnesses they heard they saw
heaven viewed what a sight for the
heavenly universe
martin do you think that the heavenly
universe was disgusted with what
happened on this planet no death yes
if you read the news
and you read the decisions of some of
the leading powers in this world
are you
cheerful or are you disgusted i'm
disgusted you're disgusted any thinking
human being
looking at the discordant voices that
are out there the nonsensical
legislations that are passed in the
world
the oppression and the violence
must tell you
that there is something seriously wrong
on a worldwide basis and you know what
what about just that one love your
neighbor
do you see that in the enforcements and
all this that you've seen in the past
two years have you seen any of those
love your neighbor what about love your
neighbor as yourself
many of the rules seem to apply only to
those that are subject to the rules but
not to those that give the rule exactly
they've twisted it
because if you don't want to eat here at
here then they throw that
same phrase that you you don't want you
don't love your neighbor
but there's no
back love
all right so
let's get to the bottom of this
discussion
why are we having this discussion
because we're hearing these voices the
time is not yet
and just to put people back
onto
a thus says the lord
do you believe
that the final events are unfolding
before our eyes yes
and christ's coming is even at the door
even at the door do we see it in the
turmoils definitely so martin what do
you suggest
for the time that we are living in i
suggest that we should start getting
more on our knees
start getting together
as a people for god's word to put it out
to the people out there
and get the fear out of our lives
but and i had a discussion the other day
and
it was with a group of people on
some islands
on this world of ours
and many of those people had lost their
jobs
because they stood for something
and they were in despair
and we had these discussions
about what do you do in a time like this
what about all these people
that are now
suddenly becoming destitute
and one of the things that i said
was
what was it like in the early church
was the early church under pressure
heavily it was heavily under pressure
right it was being persecuted
and
some of them
and even some of the disciples
were being arrested and herod even
thought it was a wonderful thing
to kill one of them as an example
so that he could get the
the sympathy of the jewish nation behind
him
and
they were hard-pressed
they
had to
stick together
and the spirit of prophecy says
in the times that we are living in that
we should
press together press together
press together
but what do you do on a practical level
well they stuck together
and people brought money and they gave
it to the disciples
and they distribute it to each one
according to his need
right
instead of defending
and hoarding the money that we have
isn't it a time that we should
think about
aiding one another assisting brothers
and sisters that are going through
straight places and hard times
so i suggested that
they actually create a fund
and that everybody
that is willing and able
contribute to that fund
so that people can be assisted when
it really is necessary
my personal feeling is this is something
that the church
should do
and if the church does not want to do
that well then let private individuals
start doing it
because we are heading for some very
straight
places and some very tough times and
especially when people are standing up
for their conscience
yes they will start going into despair
so let's stand together let's press
together
let's
help one another
and if possible
create circumstances where we do not
only help by word
but also
by deed let's pray
heavenly father
we are living in such troubles times
the world is upside down
the time is fulfilled
the time is over
and there is no time now
to think that the lord delays his coming
the lord is not delaying his coming the
signs foretell it
help us to stand together to press
together
to become an army with banners
and to proclaim the last message of
warning to the world is my prayer in
jesus name amen
[Music]
you